ce parcours est très difficile car il y a beaucoup
de la boue il faut traverser des rivières et il y en a beaucoup
monticule
Très difficile
[Musique]
est ce que nous pouvons trouver
la pluie le vent de tous n'est pas facile
choisir les deux pays pour
et atteindre un objectif
[Musique]
huit jours de marche dans la jungle
ils nous ont trompés ils nous ont laissé un point du
la jungle nous a volé cinq hommes avec
des fusils pointés sur moi dans la tête nous
ils ont emporté tous les vêtements argent passeport tout
ce que
y'a sur youtube ils lui donneraient des champs j'ai crié
faire l'expérience d'une nouvelle lecture
king live experience' et ils sont comme ça et
laisser et entre la vie dans les morts
[Musique]
si la plupart d'entre nous, les enfants, savons que
migration effectuée dans la famille ok
quand ils viennent avec des enfants sont ces cas
problèmes de déshydratation
diarrhée gastro-intestinale vomissements
également des symptômes respiratoires
problème d'exposition à la pluie
temps humide ok qui les affecte généralement
assez pour eux
[Musique]